well let's start right now we've got a
chance to get this taste out of our
mouth by playing well against buffalo
we're in a position we lead the east we
can play better we are prepared to
address the nuances
of
our subtleties or however you want to
describe them we're prepared to
take advantage of the detail that it
takes to win a football game
now that was jerry jones yesterday
morning on 105 3 the fan in dallas and
he was asked whether or not he had
considered making an in-season coaching
change and he really didn't answer the
question with a yes or a no and if
anything if you listen to what he said
carefully chris sims first of all good
morning second listen carefully to what
he said
i i really do believe even more strongly
than i did yesterday that jason garrett
could be in significant jeopardy of
losing his job during the season if the
cowboys lose to the bills tomorrow
afternoon which makes tomorrow
afternoon's game between buffalo and
dallas even more important to watch well
yeah it's important to watch regardless
i mean it's two t it's two teams
fighting for a playoff spot so that's
awesome um
this jason garrett conversation is very
interesting it's intriguing i mean yes
has it been underwhelming is he partly
to blame of course he is there there's
no denying it
challenge flag chris sims is he partly
to blame well yeah you've been crapping
on this guy for the last two and a half
years don't act like it's not your fault
now if jerry jones is finally listening
to you that's wrong not that for the
last two and a half years maybe the last
okay
maybe the last two and a half days i've
done them a lot yes oh the offense isn't
imaginative they do the same thing all
the time they don't have motion they
don't do anything to fly i like your
voice
it's only two coverages it's only two
coverages right how hard is that to
attack they don't have game plans that
are specific to each opponent come on
man i know the chris sims anti-jason
garrett greatest hits by heart well the
offense has expanded this year that's
one thing but you're right everything
else yes okay uh yeah i'll stand
corrected uh it is his fault he's the
head coach and uh at the end of the day
he is the one in charge so you know i
get all that
to me this is just where the
conversation's really interesting mike
you know again they are fighting for a
spot in the playoffs they are leading
the nfc east they are a team that is
extremely talented do you want to fire
your head coach okay
and maybe jeopardize the rest of the
year or you hang in there with him no
matter what and just hope you get uh you
know hot here at some point in december
leading into january if you do get into
the playoffs where you can go on a real
run they do have that type of talent you
know i know i've been talking about my
bar fight stuff all week like if the 52
teams in the nfl 32 teams break out in a
fight in the nfl dallas is one of those
teams that certainly could be in the top
four or top five they really are i mean
we know it we went through the position
groups yesterday it's one of the best
old lines in football it's one of the
better d-lines in football the
linebackers are phenomenal the
cornerback duo is up there in the top
five in football the receivers are good
the quarterback's good their running
backs good so do you think
that's the right move i ask you mike
florio if you lose a game this weekend
do you think you're really gonna get
better results and make a run going
december into january as to then maybe
just hanging in there with him and
hoping he can get on one of his hot
streaks that we've seen the cowboys do
aka last year or 2014 when they went on
a run and did that some of that stuff
that's to me the big question
well i don't think jerry jones says the
things he said this week if he isn't at
least contemplating it at a minimum he's
putting maximum pressure on jason
garrett because in the past when
garrett's back has been against the wall
he has delivered this is the ultimate
challenge right the gauntlet is thrown
can you deliver thursday against the
bills next thursday against the bears
can you stay
a game ahead of the eagles and maybe it
ultimately comes down to whether or not
they can beat the eagles in philadelphia
week 16. but this is applying ultimate
pressure to jason garrett to get the
most out of this season and if he
responds under pressure and if he does
get more out of the talent that jerry
jones and stephen jones in the front
office has compiled that could save him
but
if you lose to buffalo right here's the
thing yeah you've put this guy's back
firmly against the wall and you've put
him on notice he's now on notice we're
all on notice and he's on notice sure
that this is it
and if you lose thursday when your
back's against the wall yet again
then the question becomes is there
someone else on the coaching staff that
could get more right out of the talent
that we've compiled and and you think
like a guy like chris richard because
sure he's the first guy that's that's
good
that's the name that pops up right
what a great opportunity yeah if you are
going to be hiring a coach after the
season anyway if you accept the fact
that it's just not going to work this
year you give richard a chance to rally
the troops
earn the job on the fly and i always
caution against the whole concept of the
interim coach because what happens is a
bad team starts playing better to help
the interim coach get the job so they
can go back to playing poorly under the
interim coach and they don't have to
worry about a guy coming in and getting
rid of guys right this is different this
is a team with a ton of talent and
potential
and this isn't an artificial bump like
oh we got to play hard to save our butts
no this is a different guy who's getting
more out of the great players that he
has so i feel less concerned about an
interim coach in this situation and it
could be that this is the right move to
make if they lose to the bills i don't
think they're going to lose to the bills
but if they lose to the bills i could
understand the logic and i could see why
the joneses would be thinking hey you
know what we're not keeping jason
garrett next year let's just see what
chris richard can do before we go out
and try to hire some guy who may have no
connection whatsoever to the
organization yeah i hear you i you know
tomorrow i expect a tight close football
game i'm not going to just you know yeah
yeah i mean i i think ultimately i'm
gonna end up picking the dallas cowboys
but the the buffalo bills are no picnic
i mean we know that this is a top five
defense in football josh allen's
dangerous i mean the way he's been
playing lately if if he plays clean his
running and big throws and then of
course the predictability of that
defense lends itself to some of those
moments with a guy like josh allen
because they sit there all week in game
plan and go hey josh it's one of these
two defenses all game long you know
playing hard and playing tough and
hustle and all those things that's never
the cowboy's problem it's uh never is i
never watch the cowboys and go man
they're not putting the pedal to the
metal they do and that's where i give
you know jason garrett a lot of respect
yes it goes back to what you called me
out for earlier in this segment is it is
the creativity the managing of moments
that's where i wish jason garrett would
get involved maybe a little bit more on
the offensive side of the ball you talk
about chris richard what is going on
there is he the one that wants to just
play two coverages all game long if it
is i'm not all that impressed with him
either or is he being handcuffed by
jason garrett those are questions i
would like to know and have answers to
but i don't so you know at as we stand
right now
even if they lose i guess i'm taking the
stand up i wouldn't fire jason garrett
yet i wouldn't until i knew like oh man
we're out of the playoffs and this is
over because of all the things you said
they're talented they are capable of
making a run you know i would you and me
you know i don't expect this but would
you be shocked if we woke up nfc
championship sunday and the dallas
cowboys were there you know i mean i
know we would to a degree but when you
just look at the product on the field
you wouldn't i think you'd go yeah i get
it i get how this team could get on a
hot run and beat the 49ers and the
saints and do things like that so that's
where it's a really interesting decision
to me and and uh of course tomorrow i'll
be tuned in and that'll be a fun game to
watch
well and i think the ultimate litmus
test is can they hold serve at home on
thanksgiving against the bills and you
know i was talking earlier on the radio
side about the nostalgia of thanksgiving
and how the day before thanksgiving is
always kind of a special day the night
before all the smells in the house and
it brings back memories of growing up
and for the cowboys
the opponent that's rolling into town on
thursday is going to spark some
nostalgia because they beat them in
back-to-back years for super bowl
championships that's right
when you think about everything they've
invested in jason garrett and i think
back to jerry jones defending garrett
early in his time as a coach
and he was kind of learning on the fly
it was kind of like freddie kitchens
over a multi-year period and then they
decided after they put in the time and
the effort to let jason garrett grow on
the job they were going to keep him
around the question is where's his
ceiling has he hit it yeah right can he
bust through it and i think this at at
some level this is the genius of jerry
jones because it doesn't always sound
all that eloquent
but
he is consciously deliberately and
strategically
throwing down the gauntlet for jason
garrett this is his test
can you perform under this kind of
pressure if you can great if you can't
see you later and and look this is the
strongest language we've heard from
jerry jones about a coach we didn't even
hear about wade phillips they just fired
wade phillips right they didn't give him
the last clear chance warning he was
just gone after they said oh we're not
going to fire wade phillips during the
season and then they did so with with
jerry jones all bets are always off but
now that he has said what he said and he
repeated a lot of those same thoughts on
tuesday i think this is
ultimate application of pressure to
jason garrett to see how he responds and
this is his test and if he fails they
get a new coach and if he passes they
keep going yeah i i think that's fair i
do i just don't know if fail happens
this weekend you know again they know
they got some tougher games on their
schedule coming up where i just want to
go
okay when when does fail exactly hit
home with the jones family and you know
hey working for the jones family is not
exactly the easiest thing in the world
either i do think we need to take that
into account but with this particular
scenario the jones family's done a great
job of scouting signing free agents
spending money drafting big bad mofos on
each side of the ball okay they got it
all and i just don't know when that line
is i mean is it if they lost tomorrow
and then lose to the bears then maybe uh
maybe it gets to that point i just don't
know if i would do it just with the loss
tomorrow on thanksgiving because there's
still a very good chance you could get
out of this weekend still leading the
nfc east
but that's the thing you don't want to
wait too long you don't want to make the
change at a time when
you you've lost your opportunity to take
away the division right right and that
to me is why jerry jones is the
billionaire and the owner of the team
and he'll have to figure out the balance
and and make that decision ultimately
i got two quick points i want to make
before we take our first break yeah
first
i think that at some level jerry jones
is upset by the sunday splash report
that jason garrett's first choice would
be the giants if he's not retained by
the cowboys because i think jerry jones
saw through that the same way the rest
of us did this was a warning shot at the
cowboys if you get rid of jason garrett
you may have to deal with him twice per
year and i don't think jerry jones
appreciates that because he has taken
the high road throughout these efforts
with jason garrett and if they're going
to start having pressure applied to them
like that he's going to get pissed
secondly chris i was talking about this
yesterday with mds on the pftpm podcast
we were talking about what the ravens
did if i'm jerry jones and i'm making a
coaching change boy i'm thinking about
greg roman
because
i'd like to see greg roman do with
ezekiel elliott and dak prescott what
he's done with mark ingram and lamar
jackson yeah and that offensive line you
talked yesterday about how that
baltimore offensive line just mauls
everyone right cowboys have the tools to
do it and uh i i think that that's a
fascinating name to throw into the
conversation for 2020 if that's the way
that the cowboys it definitely is i just
don't know you know doc prescott we know
he's athletic and big is he that kind of
player to where you want to run that
offense around him you know yeah it'll
have to be in a more limited fashion
you're not going to be able to run lamar
jackson the way you run dak press guy
he's just not as quick not as fast not
going to be able to avoid some of those
hits that's the greatness of lamar
jackson because he is so quick nobody
really ever squares him up so
but i'm with you greg roman has deserved
or deserves the respect at least to be
in that conversation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports